ene mene muh ich wünsche mir einen harry
potter adventskalender herbei hex hex
hallo leute ich sie teure mal waren
bekommen zu einem neuen adventskalender
unboxing-video nach dem super emp
adventskalender fail freue ich mich
heute diesen harry potter pop
adventskalender auszupacken ich liebe
diese kleinen pop figuren ich habe nur
eine von bob ross an meinem
schlüsselanhänger und freue mich dass
ich harry potter von figuren kriegen wir
wissen was uns in dieser freude erwarten
wird aber vielleicht können wir ja noch
das sehen nach spielen das wäre doch
toll oder
das wird ganz schön war in diesem
scheiss so ich finde harry potter an
weihnachten passt wie arsch auf eimer
weil immer wenn ich harry potter filme
gucken habe ich dieses wohlig warme
gefühle ich möchte einen tee in meiner
hand halten oder mit 1 2 hinten und dann
so rinke trinken und mich freuen darüber
dass harry potter seine magische welt
ist so ich weiß nicht ganz genau wie der
jetzt absolut tolles verpackungsdesign
wenn der klasse a magical party in harry
potter virtual die zahlen gar nicht
wissen wie viel schon an harry potter
merge umsatz gemacht wurde
es muss so unglaublich viel sein ja wenn
wir über die verpackung sprechen wollen
ich finde sie sehr schön
ja das ist schön das ist wunderschön
die zahlen sind alle so golden und man
klappt das hier so auch und es ist
wichtig sie es aus wenn man sich das in
dein zimmer stellt es also dieser
adventskalender 60 euro gekostet ist für
diese top figuren denke ich schon ok auf
jeden fall schlimmer als bmp kann es ja
eh nicht werden
[Musik]
also freunde sind einfach darauf machen
sind denen man fans kalender erwartet
bin viel zu entscheidet man muss die
zahlen hier nicht mal suchen wir sind in
reihenfolge türchen nummer 1 gut die
sind aber winzig in kirchen nummer eins
wird man nicht enttäuscht da bekommt man
gleich harry potter für alle für diesen
winter ball an gekleidet und bitte
schreibt mir jetzt nicht in die
kommentare was für ein schlechter
reporter fern ich bin wenn ich das nicht
weiß ich weiß gar nicht wie dieser ball
heißt der weihnachtsmarkt zwei ich denke
regie genie sein
die sind alle so gekleidet für diesen
winter bald in welchem teil war der
feuerkelch harry potter und der
feuerkelch des feuers sein kann kann ich
auch den kürbis einstellen weil es
pasteten minuspunkt kann die nicht stehe
aber sehr knapp und jetzt hilft ja ich
kaufe ich lass uns mal dieses kleine
auspacken hier und wird uns nicht viel
überraschen nummern bereit die aus der
französischen schule oder ist das so
ich glaube das ist fleur delacour
dracula co fleur delacour
zum strand hier haben wir viktor chrome
mit kai niemann damit gekämpft
eigentlich verarbeitung ist schon okay
aber sie könnte tatsächlich besser sein
findet nämlich bei den großen pop
figuren ist die verarbeitung schon
richtig gut und man merkt ihr bei diesem
kleinen salz nicht so nicht so wichtig
war oder ich probleme die hier
aufzustellen le guennec kann einmalig
stehen die legt sich immer wieder hin
er ist an nikolaus drin denn die haben
denn irgendwie falsch produziert die
kann kaum stehen ich glaube bei das
kleid irgendwie keine ahnung in nummer
sechs professor snape hier wirklich voll
attraktiv ich finde aber nicht dass die
alle in extra plastik eingewickelt
werden mussten
es hätte doch gereicht wenn man die
einfach so rein gelegt hätte hier haben
wir igor karacic der die ganz schön böse
aus ganz böse macht ich möchte sagen
aber das ist nicht wahr ich glaube sie
haben raum einen besseren anzug gegeben
der hatte doch im film nicht so einen
schönen anzug anziehen wird ein von
alten zu leisten kannst du deine
schwester nummer 98
sorry das sind natürlich fred und george
auch hier hätte man auch erkennen sollen
ich finde es schön dass die alle wie
festlich irgendwie eingeflogen sind und
halten nicht in dieser klassischen
hamburg uniform
also ich vermute jetzt mal dass partner
partie ist immer 11 und ihre skizze wie
ich es nochmal ihre schwester kleines
erinnert wird wenn ihre schwester hieß
sagt es gerne eine materiell also das
ist auf jeden fall schon
also das ist auf jeden fall schon
ich frage mich gerade also man hat ja
jetzt so viele davon
das macht man jetzt damit also man muss
ja irgendwas damit machen weil wenn du
sie dir einfach auf einen schrank stellt
dann musst du da einmal die woche staub
wird was ich durch meine denen man das
damals an diesen schlimmen gemacht haben
sie einfach eine verstauben lassen immer
13a das ins all und maxi diese
riesengroße lehrerin von der
französischen schule die mit ihr wisst
schon
14a bowling damit spielen wo ich stehe
gerade so auf dem schließen der
hausmeister fish und seine katze mittens
ok ich hab' ich die hausmeister 15 ja
hier haben wir in seinem schönen gewarnt
wenn du kannst zu harry potter nicht das
haben sie damit den release gemacht
warum können die denn nicht stehen
liga steht vorne als kind hätte ich mich
so gefreut wenn ich diese figuren gehabt
hätte ihr wisst ihr was ich mir für
spiele damit ausgedacht hat ich hab halt
früher so gerne mit kleinen bildern so
gespielt wie vor sei die cola purple
verarbeitung ist wieder b 317 roberta
damit verschärft die eine anders
angezogen sind als normal
18.10 erkennen doch das ist hätte ich
bin mir zu 90 prozent sicher dass das c
track dingels müsste am englischen sein
das ist kassen level sein
neville longbottom war es das hattrick
aber wer ist denn dann dass ich glaube
dass es auf jeden fall als niedrig ist
könnten er will seinen ersten apple
fragen ob sie mal vergessen haben haben
sie natürlich nicht einstellig zu harry
weil sie sich vertragen müssen um gottes
sieht so ein lecker aussieht aus
schokolade reinbeißen und hält auch
schicke man für den stelle ich natürlich
bei einer freundin christa wie ich
plötzlich wieder zwölf werde wir haben
zeit und george das ist auf jeden fall
lohnen wie bist du noch ein riesling ich
weiß gerade mit mir das also ich beide
sehen halt ausführen
gerade ein bisschen verwirrt gegen 23
diese an dem abend schon echt super auf
stellen beziehen freunden so typischen
24 was es in 24 drin noch mal harry
potter ach so ja dann kann das noch mal
ran sein
warum hat jetzt gar nicht also einmal
gewonnen harry mit dem jackett drauf und
dann gibt es die noch mal ohne jackett
ich wüsste jetzt nicht warum man hier ja
das war der kalender
ich meine es cool wenn man jeden tag ein
türchen auf macht und eine neue top
figur bekommen ich merke aber jetzt
gerade wo ich den so auspacke was macht
man jetzt damit also man kann damit
spielen aber man hat jetzt einfach 24
figuren ich hab das jetzt auch nicht so
durchdacht als ich den bestellt
ich hab mir gedacht ein i pod
adventskalender damit aber was macht man
jetzt mit beyoncé popdiva und könnte was
damit basteln
auch wenn ich es nicht gerne sage ich
glaube dieser adventskalenders hat er so
schlecht da was eine gute idee gewesen
wäre ist ein paar figuren zu nehmen und
vielleicht so ein bisschen die szenerie
vom weihnachtsbaum aufzugreifen ein paar
dekoartikel dazu zu packen als nur diese
figuren weil was macht man jetzt mit 24
figuren
als deko ist das spiel zu übertrieben
ich habe hier so eine tisch pflanze
können wir sie so zu backen
die beste figur die ich haben will und
mini kommt hier noch dazu und versetzte
mit glück kommt noch dazu dass mit toll
super ja jetzt hat die 24 kleine
menschen kohl da bekomme ich so richtig
lust auf minimalismus wisst ihr was ich
meine
ich finde auf jeden fall jemanden der
sich darüber freuen wird macht euch
keine sorgen ich wünsche euch einen
schönen tag noch und lasst euch gut
gehen und wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten video wieder da oh mein gott
wow